la gráfica de ye igual al valor absoluto
de x se refleja sobre el eje x y se
comprime verticalmente en un factor de 8
tercios cual es la ecuación de la nueva
gráfica pensemos en esto paso a paso
vamos a dibujar unos ejes aquí este es
mi eje x y este es mi eje y y si
hablamos de la gráfica de igual al valor
absoluto de x va a lucir así en el
primer cuadrante tenemos allí igual a
equis y en el segundo cuadrante tenemos
allí igual a x negativa porque el valor
absoluto de un valor negativo es su
opuesto así luce la gráfica de igual al
valor absoluto de x y aquí nos preguntan
lo que parecen dos transformaciones
diferentes la primera que nos piden es
que se refleje sobre el eje x por lo que
vamos a voltearlo sobre el eje x así así
que ahora la gráfica luce así
por lo que la ecuación que describe esta
gráfica va a ser el opuesto de lo que
teníamos aquí cualquier valor de g que
teníamos aquí ahora será el valor
negativo de este cualquier valor de g
que teníamos en esta gráfica naranja en
esta nueva gráfica tendremos el opuesto
de ese y si esto no tiene mucho sentido
para ustedes pruébenlo con diferentes
valores en la gráfica naranja cuando x
es igual a 2 por ejemplo el valor
absoluto de 2 es 2 el valor absoluto de
menos 2 también es 2 pero ahora queremos
tomar el valor absoluto pero también el
negativo de este por lo que esta gráfica
siempre es no positiva el valor absoluto
de dos es dos pero queremos el opuesto a
este menos 2 el valor absoluto de menos
2 estos pero queremos el opuesto a este
menos 2 pero no sólo nos piden que se
refleje sobre el eje x sino también que
se comprima verticalmente en un factor
de 8 tercios
pensemos un momento en esto comprimir
verticalmente si nos hubieran dicho
estirar verticalmente en un factor de
ocho tercios
simplemente multiplicaríamos esto por
ocho tercios y a veces es útil pensar en
esto como un número mixto ocho tercios
es lo mismo que dos enteros y dos
tercios
así que si fuéramos a estirar en un
factor de dos enteros y dos tercios
nuestra gráfica sería más alta se vería
algo así pero si la vamos a comprimir
entonces va a lucir así si vamos a
comprimir algo verticalmente también
podríamos pensar que se va a estirar
horizontalmente
así que si comprimimos en cierto factor
deberemos multiplicar por el recíproco
de este factor piensen en ello si
fuéramos a comprimir esto en tres lo
multiplicamos por un tercio si lo
comprimimos verticalmente por ocho
tercios significa que lo que sea que
obtuvimos aquí lo vamos a multiplicar
por el recíproco de ocho tercios
en la que pueden ver esto es en que
vamos a dividir esto entre ocho tercios
si queremos obtener esto de acá esto
será igual al valor negativo del valor
absoluto de x entre ocho tercios y
dividir entre ocho tercios es lo mismo
que multiplicar esto por el recíproco
tres octavos y nos queda menos tres
octavos por el valor absoluto de equis y
si vemos nuestras opciones nos damos
cuenta que la opción que buscamos es
esta y de nuevo quiero hacer énfasis en
este punto ya que puede ser algo confuso
la razón por la que multiplicó por el
recíproco cuando aquí me dice que
comprima verticalmente es que si nos
hubieran dicho que estiramos
verticalmente lo multiplicamos por este
factor pero como nos piden comprimir
entonces tendremos que dividir entre
ocho tercios o multiplicarlo por su
recíproco